hi guys
I am Julia and I am a justice reporter
and today we are at the Amsterdam Court of Appeal
and in this video I am going to tell you
what exactly 1 court does
the court
also what is called HOF is judicial body
the COURT speaks in second instance
this means that the COURT is handling 1 case
on appeal
after the court has already considered the case
The Netherlands has 4 areas for appeal
the so-called resort
namely in Amsterdam
Den Bosch The Hague and Arnhem Leeuwarden
let's take a look inside the court
well welcome everyone in 1 cityxale of the court
but what does 1 HOF actually do
if you don't agree
are with the verdict of the court
you can appeal 1
1 appeal is reviewed to the case
also the facts are being reassessed
but after 1 decision of the COURT
the facts are officially established
this means that about the facts
can no longer be litigated